[Musique]
quelque part en france en 1917 la dix
septième division d'infanterie
américaine s'est installé 15 passionnés
ont reconstruit un campement type ou
presque s'est inscrit dans le devoir de
mémoire et c'est quelque chose auquel on
tient absolument c'est à dire que pour
nous il n'ya pas mieux que l'histoire
vivante pour montrer aux gens ce qui
était la réalité du terrain
si les costumes et certaines temps ne
sont pas d'époque elle les outils week
comme certaines armes ou ces fioles
médical comme celle ci par exemple qui
m'a toujours un petit peu impressionnés
puisque le premier terme que l'on voit
en rouge ces poisons et en fait on est
bien sûr un avril 1916 où 18 je ne sais
plus et le terme de poison sur celle ci
elle est simplement marquer parce que
c'est à base de mercure et des témoins
du passé pour mieux comprendre le
conflit et certaines avancées notamment
médicale et ce n'est qu'à partir du
moment où
les chercheurs les médecins sur site et
tout le corps médical s'est rendu compte
que l'hygiène était primordial qu'on a
commencé à stériliser les outils qu'on a
purifié l'eau qu'on va laver le linge
une plongée dans l'histoire partagée
avec le public qui a bravé le froid et
je trouve que c'est agréable
ne serait ce que pour les enfants leur
montrer un petit peu une idée de ce que
c'était à cette époque là je trouve que
c'est excellent pour la mémoire cela
fait et puis un témoignage un témoignage
autant pour les jeunes que pour nous est
la dix septième compagnie a perdu près
de 5000 hommes en lorraine lors de la
première guerre mondiale
ces soldats sont entrés chez eux à la
fin du week-end en revenus en 2018